مدمره امريكيه تشعل توترا بحريا مع الصين
يهدد بحرب النوويه اذا اعتقل بوتين
لاول مره في تاريخها لندن تتزين في شهر
رمضان
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
في وقت يتصاعد التوتر بين الولايات
المتحده والصين في منطقه بحر الصين
الجنوبيه تسببت المدمره الامريكيه ميليوس
بازمه بحريه بين الجانبين الجيش الصيني
قال انه طرد المدمره بعد دخولها المياه
الاقليميه بشكل غير قانوني حول جزر
باراسيل في بحر الصين الجنوبي مضيفا ان
قواته ستبقى متاهبه في جميع الاوقات في
مسارع الجيش الامريكي لنفي تصريحات بكين
معتبرا انها كاذبه وان امريكا ستواصل
الابحار في المنطقه وفقا للقانون الدولي
تهديد النووي جديد اطلقه نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي دمتري مداف ضد الغرب محذرا
ان احتمال القبض على رئيس بلاده بلاديمير
بوتين في الخارج سيؤدي الى حرب نوويه كلام
جاء بعد ايام من اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه
مذكره توقيفا بحق بوتين بتهمه اشتراكه
بجرائم حرب فيما اكداف ان روسيا تتمتع
بتفوق في مجال الاسلحه النوويه ولولا ذلك
لكانوا مزقوها بحسب تعبيره
لاول مره في تاريخ العاصمه البريطانيه
تزين شارع كوفنتري احد اكبر ميادين لندن
باكثر من 30 الف مصباح احتفاء بقدوم شهر
رمضان المبارك عمده لندن صادق خان شارك في
اضاءه الفوانيس وهو واحد من بين اكثر من
مليون مسلم يقيمون في لندن ويحتفلون بشهر
رمضان سنويا فيما ستقام فعاليات رماديه
رمضانيه في مناطق اخرى في العاصمه من
بينها افطار مفتوح في متحف
انطلق لكنه فشل في الوصول اول صاروخ مصنوع
بتقنيه الطابعه ثلاثيه الابعاد فشل في
الوصول الى الفضاء بعد ان تم اطلاقه من
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه بسبب خلل ترى
اثناء الرحلات تيران واحد الذي طورته شركه
هو صاروخ غير ماهول كان يفترض به ان يثبت
بان مركبه فضائيه مصنوعه بتقنيه 3d يمكنها
ان تتحمل العوامل القاسيه شانها شان
المركبات الفضائيه العاديه لكنه لم ينجح
بذلك
بعد نحو 200 عام على وفاته وباستخدام خمس
خصولات من شعره استطاع العلماء معرفه سبب
الدقيق لوفاه العبقريه الموسيقي بيتهوفن
العلماء توصلوا الى تسلسل الجينوم الخاص
وبالتالي السبب الذي اودى بحياته حيث تبين
انه كان لديه استعداد وراثي للاصابه
بامراض الكبد كما كان مصابا بفيروس التهاب
الكبد b يذكر ان تشريح جثه بخوف كان اظهر
فعلا انه مصاب بتليف الكبد لكن البحث
الجديد اشار الى وجود عوامل عديده وراء
مرضه